hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for
anime outro and today i will be talking
about the huge news that has been slowly
leaking out
regarding the seven deadly sins a brand
new
seven deadly sins movie will be coming
out
this summer the summer of 2021
and it will feature a new story written
by the original mangaka
nakabasuzuki judging by the title of
this upcoming movie
this new story could be that
long-awaited supreme deity arc
which was of course the one major
missing piece
from the original seven deadly sins
manga on top of the big movie news
in this video i will also cover the
latest developments in the direct
sequel to the seven deadly sin story
called four nights of the apocalypse
which is currently coming out weekly so
stay tuned
and let's get into it if you enjoy our
seven deadly sins videos and you want to
see more videos about the 7 deadly sins
and the sequel in the future
please do me a favor and leave a like
and comment
it only takes a second and you might
think that it doesn't matter but it
actually matters a lot for the youtube
algorithm and if you don't want to miss
future videos on the seven deadly sins
and the sequel don't forget to subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all
notifications alright so our knowledge
about this new seven deadly sins movie
is still limited the news is quite fresh
but we do know that this is indeed new
content
that wasn't covered in the original
manga and we also know that the title of
the movie
is cursed by light because we don't have
a lot of specifics i will have to
speculate here but that title cursed by
light
heavily implies that this movie might be
dealing
with the supreme deity as you will
recall the single
biggest unsolved mystery in the original
seven deadly sins manga
was the supreme deity she was the other
major villain of the story along with
the demon king
but while the demon king got ample
screen time in multiple arcs
the supreme deity didn't get any time to
shine
no pun intended we only know the supreme
deity through a flashback which showed
how meliotas and elizabeth were defeated
and cursed by her and the demon king
3000 years ago
while reading the original manga i was
convinced that after the demon king arc
we would get a supreme deity arc as well
after all the supreme deity and the
demon king were supposed to be
equally powerful and they were equally
responsible for the destruction of
belialuin
for all those bloody holy wars and of
course for cursing meliotis and
elizabeth
i was certain that the holy wars could
never truly end
until both the demon king and the
supreme deity were defeated
taking out only one of them is not
enough because that would just
embolden the other one to keep doing
what they were doing the whole time
except this time they don't have an
opposing force
but to my great surprise and to the
surprise of many other fans
in the original manga we never got a
supreme deity arc
and we never got to see the celestial
realm at all
the big demon king arc was followed by
the king of chaos arc
and then the series simply ended the
fact that we never got a supreme deity
arc
made the whole story feel unfinished at
least in my
personal opinion and i know that many
others felt that way as well
but now we get this news about a movie
that will feature a new story
something not yet featured in the manga
and what do you know
the title of the movie is cursed by
light
light and the power of light is closely
associated with the goddess clan
and the supreme deity is of course the
ruler of the goddess clan
on top of that the supreme deity is
known for cursing people
and she was the one who cursed meliodas
with immortality in the first place
so to me it only makes sense that the
title
cursed by light is a reference to the
supreme deity
and to the celestial realm i really hope
that this new movie
is going to give us that long-awaited
supreme deity arc
and i hope that we will finally get the
answers to all of those big
unsolved mysteries about the supreme
deity and before you say that this movie
won't be canon so what happens won't
have an impact on the original story
i have to once again mention that the
first seven deadly sins movie called
prisoners of the sky included multiple
references to people and places that
ended up being canon in the original
story
this includes the sky temple and the
celestials
the mother of chaos and more so it is
possible that this new movie will
actually
add to the established canon of the
story
meaning that we absolutely should be
paying attention to the movie
and the new information that the movie
will reveal my personal prediction is
that this movie
will be canon and that it will take
place sometime
after the fight with kath paluk and of
course i think that the focus will be on
the supreme deity and the celestial
realm
this is all speculation at this point
for all i know it could end up being a
prequel series that takes place during
the time of the original holy war
but i'd love to know what you guys think
is this new movie finally going to give
us
that elusive supreme deity arc
is it going to be canon in terms of the
original story
or will it just be filler and when do
you think that the events of the story
will
take place in terms of the original
seven deadly sins timeline
is it going to take place between some
of the older arcs is it going to be a
prequel
is it going to take place during the 10
year time skip at the end of the manga
or will it be sometime closer to the
timeline of the four nights of the
apocalypse
sequel definitely share your thoughts on
this crazy movie news
down in the comments below now let's
talk about the latest developments in
the seven deadly sins
sequel series the four nights of the
apocalypse which has
three published chapters as of the
making of this video
and of course it is being published
weekly by kodansha
i already made an entire video on the
first chapter of this manga
a chapter which was over 60 pages long
so definitely check that out if you
haven't already
the link will be in the description and
also in the pinned comment
so far i am really enjoying the story
and the latest chapters gave me strong
meliotis vibes from the new main
character
percival and on top of that we also got
a clue that characters from the original
series
may be showing up soon in the sequel
especially
merlin and arthur chapters 2 and 3
feature percival's descent from god's
finger into the land of britannia
and the various characters and
challenges that he encounters
along the way it takes him over a day to
climb all the way down
and after a pretty rough landing
percival comes face to face with the fox
creature that was featured on the front
cover
of the first chapter this fox is clearly
going to become important to the story
and i'm guessing it will probably become
percival's companion
percival is amused when he comes across
this creature because there were no
foxes on top of god's finger
and the fox eventually leads percival to
some fellow human beings
these humans are three magical street
performers who are practicing for their
next
show the troupe includes katz the leader
of the troop
elba a teenage girl and donny a teenage
boy who kinda looks and acts like a
delinquent
percival is impressed with the troops
magic tricks so he comes out of hiding
and
greets them but when donnie realizes
that percival is pretty much clueless
about the world beyond god's finger
he tries to steal all percival stuff by
making percival levitate and then taking
off
with his bag the other two members of
the troop don't really want to leave
percival out there alone
to them he looks like a little kid and
they're concerned that him being out
there on his own
could lead to trouble however to
everyone's great surprise
once the levitation magic wears off
percival takes off in a sprint
and easily catches up to the horse and
carriage realizing that percival
probably shouldn't be messed with donnie
returns his stuff
that's when percival reveals that he is
looking for his father
ironside and that he needs help finding
him
the troop has no idea who ironside is
but they do agree to take percival to a
nearby village
in the hope that someone there might
know about
ironside on the way to the village the
members of the troop reveal that at some
point in the past
they all wanted to become holy knights
but
they failed they don't really possess
any strong
magic the only thing that their magic is
good for is performing
cheap tricks so they became street
performers
once percival and the troop reach the
village they are shocked to see that a
giant wolf
is rampaging around the village this
wolf has some sort of demon-esque
mark on its tail just like that blue
demon from god's finger
and i have to say that the art style of
this wolf really reminded me of kath
pauluk from the king of chaos arc in the
original manga
now obviously this wolf is nowhere near
as powerful as kath
palug and percival actually beats him
easily by [ __ ] slapping him right in
the face
once the wolf is defeated the
demon-esque mark disappears from its
tail
and percival is celebrated as a hero
it's worth mentioning that
when it looked like percival was in
trouble at the very beginning of this
short fight donnie actually stepped in
to help
percival at the expense of getting
injured so it seems that dony is a good
guy after all
he was just extremely jaded and
resentful after failing to get into the
holy knights
meanwhile that fox from earlier watched
as the entire fight against the wolf
unfolded
and through some sort of magic crystal
there was someone else
watching as well inside a castle
somewhere
a fully armored knight is impressed that
percival was able to defeat his familiar
and it's clear that this knight is
plotting something
but here's the crazy thing in that last
panel of the second
chapter right behind the knight we see a
mural
on the window that depicts the battle
against kath palug from the original
seven deadly sins manga we can see
arthur using excalibur to fight kath
we see merlin right next to him and we
see other people there too
presumably these guys are supposed to
symbolize the other heroes who were
there during that fight
although to be honest these depictions
don't exactly look like the real
characters we know
one of them does have wings though so
perhaps that one is supposed to be
elizabeth
and another one has a mustache but i
don't think it's supposed to be escanor
since he wasn't
around for that fight either way this
mural
is a very cool easter egg and it is an
indication that the characters we love
from the original story
will appear in this sequel at some point
in the future
since this story is presumably taking
place in camelot
merlin and arthur will likely be the
first characters that we get to see
again
but we'll have to wait and see chapter 3
begins with the aftermath of percival's
triumph over the giant wolf
which saved the village from destruction
the villagers are wondering how this
wolf became so big
and apparently similar strange monsters
have been appearing in other villages
too
clearly these holy nights or former holy
nights like ironside
and the knight from the last chapter are
playing with some sort of
dark magic perhaps even demon magic
and they must be using this magic to
create these
familiars why they are doing it and why
they want to terrorize
random villages is still a mystery to me
but i'm sure we will find out more
soon right after that we witness a scene
that is quite
something alba the female troop member
is bathing with percival in the river
and she is completely
naked so here's the thing she seems to
think that percival is just a little kid
so she has no problem being naked around
him and helping him to clean himself
after all this kid isn't even in puberty
yet so what's the big deal
or at least that's what elba thinks
except as we know
percival is already 16 years old he just
looks really young
and as it turns out elba and donny are
also
16. but as of this point in the story
elba has no idea that percival is
actually her own age
so she keeps bathing with him as he
squeezes her chest and admires
the rest of her naked body now in
percival's defense
he had never even seen a woman before in
his entire life so he has no idea how to
properly behave
in a situation such as this and of
course elba was totally cool with
bathing with him because she thought
that he was just a little kid
in fact it was probably her idea since
she thought that she was helping out
this dirty little kid
all in all though this scene was
hilarious and it definitely gave me some
major meliotis vibes
when percival and elba get back into
town everyone wants to celebrate and
toast percival for his brave actions
against the wolf
and it is during this celebration that
we learned that elba
donny and percival are all the same age
as soon as she hears this elba spits out
her drink and her face is flushed with
color as she realizes that she was just
bathing naked with a boy her own
age and i have to say that this was a
hilarious moment and as i said earlier
i was getting heavy meliotis vibes
throughout this
chapter percival then tries asking the
villagers about the knight in the red
armor his father ironside
but no one seems to know anything about
him however
another knight suddenly shows up to
crash the party
this is a knight who wears black armor
and it is the
same night from the end of chapter 2.
the black knight's name is
pelgart and he calls himself a fellow of
bulges and ironside
so presumably a fellow holy knight
although he could be a former holy
knight who actually betrayed king arthur
just like ironside had done
it is clear right off the bat that the
black knight is far
stronger than the average human and no
one in the village except for percival
stands a chance
against him so percival decides to
challenge him to a fight
saying that if he wins then the black
knight must tell
percival where his father is the black
knight agrees but he also says that if
he wins
then percival has to agree to come along
with him the black knight is surprised
by percival's strength and his ability
to actually put up a fight
using nothing but his bare hands so
pelgart wants to raise percival
as his own disciple unfortunately for
percival
without a weapon and without any magic
he simply can't take the black
knight down it really doesn't look good
for percival
as the black knight seems to be
dominating the fight but
then that fox that has been watching the
entire thing unfold
appears to do something or say something
and then
suddenly percival's fists are enveloped
by some sort of
magical energy this unknown power forces
the black knight back
and even he doesn't know what kind of
magic this is
and that is how this chapter the third
chapter
ends man i am definitely enjoying this
story
so far this is a strong beginning for a
brand new manga adventure
and i'm very curious to learn more about
percival's powers
and the true intentions of ironside and
on top of all the action and mystery we
already have some great humor elements
like the elba scene which reminds me a
lot of the original seven deadly sins
i gotta admit i do hope that we're gonna
see the return of at least some of the
characters from the original manga
sometime soon including of course
tristan and lancelot
since i'm sure they're going to be main
characters in this story
along with percival but let me know what
you guys think what kind of magic
does percival have is this a latent
power of his own
or is it related to that mysterious fox
also
what's the deal with ironside and
pelgart they don't seem like good guys
so are they both traitors who are using
forbidden magic like maybe demon magic
or a fragment of chaos magic
like did they maybe steal a fragment of
chaos from king arthur
and if so what is their ultimate goal
why are they using familiars to
terrorize these innocent villagers
finally assuming that all of this is
taking place in camelot
what do you think that arthur and merlin
are up to why don't they do something to
stop these
sketchy knights like ironside and
pelgard are they maybe busy dealing with
an
even bigger threat don't forget to share
your thoughts down in the comments below
if you enjoyed this video and you want
to see more seven deadly sins
and sequel videos please leave that like
and subscribe it really means a lot
remember that once you subscribe you
also have to go through the trouble of
hitting that bell
and then selecting the option that says
all i know it's annoying it's an extra
step but if you don't do that you're
still gonna miss a ton of our videos
even if you are subscribed
it's just how youtube works you can also
hit me up on twitter
and instagram at anime uproar
a big thank you to all of our anime
uproar patrons for making videos like
this one possible
special thank you to alpha sigma
disciple of lord twego
himself and i can't forget all of our
the one
tier patrons the ones who rise above all
other clans
including ingrata the world acquired
respect pate heffa liam thompson
al-jatal
dr cortman johnny boy draws emperor
otaku spidey life canal
big buddhist and tungsten tarkis finally
thank you to all of our pro hero tier
patrons including the one and only
gilgamesh steelers
angel cruz anatoly kazatsky joe stanton
very gucci jessica califond rathu in
deora alicia octor bonnie parks hinokami
and water the red-haired raven joanne
garcia jack watches anime fat boy games
deadly saint matthew cruz and
anthony schreiber if you enjoy our
videos and you feel that they provide
value to you consider supporting us
on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our patron exclusive
discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these
legendary people as always thank you
guys so much for watching
and until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you